all right if you say we can't have
demons on disney you're crazy that's all
i'm saying steven needs jesus right now
what is going on what is this
what i don't know but i love it
[Music]
oh my god
i'm sorry
i am so
so
for real
for one once
i feel weird marvel anymore i i got the
chills eric oh my god yo that was
insanity insanity
i
love this episode what the heck i did
too
i can't believe they did this this is
crazy this is great welcome back to new
rock stars marvel studios what if
episode 4 just gave us the most
heartbreaking horrific and bleakest half
hour we have ever seen following the
marvel studios title mephisto confirmed
i mean honestly who cares that's like
the fifth craziest thing to have in this
episode because what the
[Applause]
this is inside marvel it's our after
show for marvel's what if on disney plus
i'm eric voss my easter egg breakdown is
gonna come to the channel tomorrow but
right now we are asking how the tragic
strange supreme might actually return in
live action mcu multiverse of madness
maybe even be the doctor strange we see
in spider-man no way home
i'm reacting to this and this whole ifed
up episode with mt
how do you feel after that bro um i feel
that doctor strange definitely needed
some therapy because good god he uh he
did some crazy things in this episode
but let's just say that wow i loved it
it's so good so i feel like the episodes
in the season just keep getting better
and better so like i'm so excited
i agree so in a universe in which
stephen strange dates christine palmer
christine dies in the car accident and
sets strange on this journey to become
the sorcerer's supreme but now he uses
the time stone to try to save christine
but uh like the elderly homeless man in
groundhog day she just dies again and
again it was just her time or someone up
there hates her guts
or loves her i have a theory on that
later
but the ancient one tells strange that
her death is what is called an absolute
point and anytime they capitalize this
[ __ ] i'm like okay we got a new term i
love it i love it i love it
but strange says f that i don't care and
he persists and uh he it's traveled to
this lost library of cagliostro where he
spends it turns out centuries absorbing
countless mystic beans including a
little garden home
[Laughter]
i want to travel i want to see the world
that was energy number one
yeah i know that's the first
the most powerful being that i know
let's the beetle walk but not the gnome
they taste delicious um but crazily
enough this includes that tentacled
entity from episode one we got some
continuity now going on we're back on
the continuity train interesting we'll
talk about what that is uh but he
realized at the end of all this at the
each one it actually split his soul so
there's another good strange one who
decided to move on from christine and
finds uh his reality now inking away not
dust they used a new kind of sludge
whatever that is i loved how that looked
it looks so cool it's like wow upside
down am i in a lava lamp what's going on
here yeah i would be like just take me
this feels great i don't know where i'm
going
back to that primordial ooze i want to
be a part of that postmortial ooze right
thank you very much
um
but uh you know for whatever reason they
don't want this to happen so at least in
this battle of strange versus strange uh
an insane wizard duel and strange
supreme wins he sucks himself in
nice
he turns into this monster who saves
christine but christine's like oh no
thank you no thank you
and uh all of reality erases
leaving us with this bleak finale where
the watcher who strange is able to see
now he's so powerful we can see the
watcher uh and the watch is like no i
don't intervene
no thanks last time i tried to do that
at my daughter's birthday party she
hates me she doesn't talk to me anymore
she says i'm a bad dad so i'm not doing
that to you and he likes this universe
die and then credits
well just cut straight to credits i have
a theory that this is not the last we
will see of strange supreme this tragic
thing okay okay i obviously this episode
rewrote the multiverse rules again in
the mcu but i think that will clue us
into how multiverse of madness will look
and work so we should talk about all the
new terms we got uh but before we get to
that our merch partners at epic hero
shop have a new shirt design inspired by
spider-man no way home and the what if
shirt that i'm wearing right now both of
these shirts are unique limited edition
designs that aren't going to be around
for long so head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to grab one now now
there is other what if inspired merch
stuff inspired by suicide squad and loki
other properties with some cool hoodies
and jackets to help you get ready for
the cooler temperatures happening right
now and uh when you buy one of our
latest obsession shirts at new
rockstarsmerch.com you get the chance to
leave a custom shout out that runs
during our inside marvel after shows
let's see what we got here uh oj holmes
asks what if the watcher and kang were
old friends i love that theory that's my
hope that by the end of this we'll see
some kind of connection between those
two oh yeah like in the comics the tva
and the watcher have some type of
relationship so like i think that kang
and he or at least he will remain know
each other so that would be interesting
yeah and what was interesting in this
episode we actually saw uh the watcher's
face it wasn't just his eyes and a star
we saw his mouth and face move so he
each episode we're starting to get more
and more of his uh
uh tangibility uh and humanity i was
gonna say humanity he's not human
obviously but it's starting to become
more and more of a person that we can
kind of see he's a handsome man who knew
and yeah what
what a man
uh dylan says could no way home
introduce the web of life and destiny um
a bit off topic but an interesting
question nonetheless and could be on
topic with if we have an episode that
rewrites the multiverse rules again
uh i i don't know if specifically
they'll they'll call it the web of life
and destiny um they may call it just
just because the movies
often don't
use the exact terms uh that the comics
introduce they just kind of call it
their own thing but i mean if if it's
just like some kind of multiversal void
that looks vaguely
spider-webby why not
we can call it the web of life and
destiny i i'm exactly on that same page
yeah co-side and then kylan bentley says
what if vos was mephisto i mean whoa
yeah i mean
i mean who knows i don't know i mean
i feel like you would have to have
mephisto powers to look that handsome i
mean i don't know or mephisto powers to
just look like this
[Laughter]
don't be like that eric you're a
handsome man
whatever that's not that's not what this
is about what this is about
is this episode of what if so what's our
first big question coming out of this
episode mt well eric what if strange
supreme comes back in the live action
mcu because i feel like that's a big
thing that could happen
yeah especially the way the multiverse
logic seems to be working because this
episode's bleak ending implies that the
doctor strange in this universe is
forever trapped in whatever is left of
this universe it kind of looks like a
condensed prism geode right but a geode
from the outside yeah it's like a little
a little crystal ball like a you know a
little uh glass thingy
at a yard sale
yeah right
and it seems like he's it's almost like
he's in there for all of eternity right
like can he die at that point is he just
stuck there crying yeah i think he's
probably just like probably condensed in
this prism like really really small just
stuck there until hopefully captain
carter maybe or somebody can help him
out right yeah the watcher calls this
the end of this universe but of course
what if is a series about the multiverse
and each episode is set in a new
universe so you know some of these
universes are probably going to end and
it's okay there's still the rest of the
multiverse to look forward to uh but one
thing i found interesting about these
first four episodes is that while they
start out as one what if scenario in
their title they later reveal themselves
to actually be a deeper what-if
hypothetical so like episode one started
as what if it was peggy carter but
really it's what if red skull decided he
want to use the tesseract to open
portals instead of conquer the planet
episode two started as what if t'challa
was star-lord but really was more of an
episode of what if thanos was the good
guy and the collector took his place and
then we saw this in episode three last
week what if the avengers were murdered
sure but really it's what if hope van
dyne was an og avenger and then that
would lead to her dying and hank going
crazy and then that's what caused all
their deaths so now episode four starts
as what if christine palmer died but
really it's what if doctor strange was
so reckless
that he went so extreme and destroyed
the universe
and i think that's super fitting because
the biggest event in marvel news this
past week was of course the spider-man
no way home trailer from which
everyone's biggest question was why the
hell is dr strange so weird and reckless
why you so weird stephen
why are you taking it so far steven
seriously we're all ready to go home and
you wanted another round
well i think we get some new possible
explanations for strange's behavior from
this episode a he could be the version
of doctor strange we saw at the end of
this what if episode having somehow
escaped this hell perhaps via sylvie or
wanda or someone else breaking this
reality and now he has replaced the
strange of the mcu more willing to
recklessly use sorcery to fix everything
but will ultimately himself have no way
home
that's why this guy's weird that's why
he's dangerous this is a guy who has
like lived this lifetime of sucking in
all these mystical entities trying to
save his girlfriend and then broke his
heart and now he has a chance to make
things right
he's like i gotta gnome in me peter what
nothing
uh i just think that would give us an
excuse of why he's so willing to use the
spell to try to like fix everything in a
specific way um but another option is
that b maybe the ancient one split this
strange we saw no way home into two
halves one good one selfish and in no
way home we could be looking at just
half a strange oh
okay so like maybe in this scenario this
other half of the strange is like maybe
trying to trick peter to maybe uh
be whole again i don't know right um
yeah going through the multiverse try to
look for another half of him yeah he
maybe is like the nice guy because
there's something also creepy about an
all nice person you kind of need to have
your mix of your pure and your toxic
selves in there and it's true
you kind of
well no you can't question mr rogers
that guy is a pure a ball of light
he's on a different plane than the rest
of us
unimpeachable um but
there is a c option that maybe this
episode will have nothing to do with
spider-man no way home and that's
totally possible i know um but i just
think there's a very strong likelihood
that we will see strange supreme again
at least maybe in multiverse of madness
because this episode was the first
episode of the series i think to feature
every voice actor from the movies on
board right like they didn't have other
actors voicing them we had been at a
cumberbatch tilda swinton benedict
cumberbatch rachel mcadams now
chippewatel agent 4 as mordo was missing
he didn't factor into this plot but i'm
just saying they didn't have someone
else uh a
voice in them and to me i think that
could be a signal that this cast might
view this story that we just saw as
essential to their character's journeys
in some way i think another thing that
surprised me about whatif is how many of
these episodes are not staying limited
to their own hypothetical realities like
episode one and four
transcended dimensions within their run
times they both had the same
interdimensional squid even squid's
everywhere
it's just one squid this thing is like a
recurring character he needs to be top
billed in the credits with jeffrey
wright
it is literally the main character of
the series of the squid what's going on
and featuring squid monster
just my legs for now
all legs legs for days to stay
all the way we just get like you know
the season when we get the tip of the
leg and then like season two we get more
of the leg and then like as seasons
progress we just get more and more to
the face that'd be hilarious yes i think
throughout the series we're getting more
and more ways the multiverse could have
been destabilized in the mcu like right
was it wanda reading the dark gold
that's what we assumed it was but no
actually it was sophie killing he who
remains oh wait no now it's peter parker
tampering with dr strange's spell and
now all the stuff what if i think empty
we're going to learn that all of these
events were synced and linked
so
and i think it could be how strange
supreme gets freed from that crystalline
hell that he's left in i i think that
this is a really good point that you
bring up because like this also brings
up a good um argument for he who remains
because he was like yo madness would
happen if i wasn't around doing what i
do so like all of these crazy things
from spider-man to this what if episode
all of this is happening and like what
if this is happening because there's no
tva so like i think that this gives a
good uh you know like wrangling in the
chaos argument for he who remains there
but you know yeah there's a longer
discussion to be had about causality
what caused what what was caused by what
you know and i i think you can make an
argument it's like a two-way street uh
and it's a street that is just like um
uh
i mean it's not even a street it's just
like one of those roundabouts in europe
around the arctic tree
or in new england uh we got a like crazy
roundabouts over here it's uh it's all
around about you
well can i tell you my reach theory for
a strange supreme t do it man i love
your reach theories i think that he
could have been the one who sent all
those cars and random causes of death
that killed christine because let's face
it you can call it an absolute point all
you want but it is crazy how much fate
had it out for her yeah she's just
dancing at one point she's like
[Applause]
it's like i have a heart attack now like
i looked very healthy up until this
point now i'm dead i mean that was the
craziest one and then from there they
went down to eating pizza and then a mug
or some reason like i'm gonna shoot this
random person and add a murder charge to
my counselor like you got anchovies
i think this could have been strange
supreme fixing his mess
making sure that she is this absolute
point who gets killed despite how much
his alternate self is trying to save her
like maybe if we zoomed in on that
mugger's face that was dr strange like
oh yeah
and then we're gonna see some future
episode actually we know we're gonna see
a future episode because in promo
footage there is a shot of strange
supreme meeting with captain carter
right right so yeah there is there's an
opportunity there there's going to be a
future opportunity this season where we
can get some more answers on what
exactly is next for both these
characters and what exactly happened
when they tussled with the tentacle
monster
and what exactly that is is it schuma
gorath is this going to be the villain
that we see i have a feeling that it
could be shumagoreth especially um at
the end of the episode because like when
strange does this little shoot i'm gonna
shoot my my darkness energy because
everything's closing around me um his
aya agamoto turns red and i was like
that's a very interesting piece of
imagery there because i think that could
be foreshadowing towards this schumacher
entity that could be coming later
agreed and i think it's interesting how
the way he eventually was able to suck
in pieces of the tentacle monster is by
just
slicing off and then they continue to
wriggle like you know um lizard tales
yeah then they still kind of had that
sentience and he was able to just take
in that those calamari chunks and when
captain carter returned from the past
through the portal there were chunks of
that squid everywhere
you know using the logic of that those
squid pieces would still have sentience
in it and they could still study it and
it could still pose a threat to whatever
future marvel universe she ended up in
oh absolutely so maybe that's how we're
not done maybe that's how we're gonna
see
this different uh pieces of whether it's
uh whether it's schumacherath or one of
the other elder gods many angled ones um
i think we're gonna see an infection
that takes over various different
realities and that's now what dr strange
might have to deal with in multiverse of
madness
oh absolutely and like like you said
like at the end of episode one uh these
tentacles are in
the future reality so shield is probably
experimenting on these and shield is
hydra and hydra likes to push the bounds
of science in like what they experiment
on so this could be good something bad's
gonna happen with these tentacles
now for now we keep talking about the
legs right are we just seeing the legs
of something else so just like some like
a fat old man who's like bears are just
my legs and you keep taking my legs and
i don't like that i don't and i played
by a billy bob thorpe
and my name's mephisto and i got weird
squid legs like is this are we just
looking at some marvel ursula and there
is some kind of humanoid uh top half to
them or is this all just a ball of squid
legs i would love if it was just one
entity and they're just getting pissed
because people keep cutting off his
limbs i think that would be that's the
perfect motivation right there it's like
stop cutting my [ __ ] off man just trying
to live
uh i can't wait to see the top half of
this squib thing i want to see arms i
want to see neck i want to see ears
i want to just zoom out and tell me what
this is seriously this feels like uh the
powerpuff girls where we couldn't see
mrs bellum uh the secretary for so long
like that we're like muppet babies and
we were just seeing nanny legs exactly
exactly
yep and then episode muppet babies where
ganzo cut off one of nanny's legs as i
said i can use this to bring back
camilla
classic episode of the muppets i watch
it all the time
well uh we have more about this episode
we want to talk about but first thanks
to our friends at feels for sponsoring
this episode cbd isn't about what you
feel it's about what you don't feel
stress anxiety pain and feels is a
better way to feel better feels is a
premium cbd that will help you keep your
head clear and feel your best it's
hassle-free delivered directly to your
door cbd naturally helps reduce stress
anxiety pain and sleeplessness there's
no hangover or addiction different folks
at new rock stars have used fuels to
help with exercise related pain and
sleeplessness caused by stress place a
few drops of fields under your tongue
and feel the difference within minutes
the thing to remember about cbd is that
finding your right dose is important
peels offers a free cbd hotline to help
guide your personal experience so that
you find your perfect dose the fields
customer service team makes sure you get
the best use of your cbd joining feels
monthly membership makes your self-care
easy you'll save money on every order
and you can pause or cancel any time
start feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com
marvel and you'll get 50 off your first
order with free shipping that's f e a l
s dot com slash marvel to become a
member and get 50 automatically taken
off your first order with free shipping
feels dot com slash marvel uh we also
want to thank cuts clothing for
sponsoring this episode here at new
rockstars we're really proud of recently
crossing 3 million subscribers and our
friends that cut clothing are proud that
they're celebrating five years of
creating great clothing whatever
milestone of accomplishment you are
proud of cuts clothing is here to make
you look as good as you feel to mark
five years of creating clothing that can
be dressed up or down for anything cuts
is having a month-long anniversary
celebration and they're doing it big
with two collection drops a product
launch and a week-long special event
cuts helps you get ready and stay ready
for any occasion with clothes that
combine classic designs universally
flattering fits and next level textile
technology at new rock stars philip in
particular is a huge fan of cuts
clothing he always says their shirts are
the best thing best fitting and that guy
let me tell you no shirts
cuts hoodies feature specially developed
hyperloop french terry fabric a material
that's temperature controlled and
ageless just like paul rudd is ageless
or try the wrinkle free pika polo a
design that keeps you looking good at
the office the golf course or even your
next hot date go to cutsclothing.com
wandavision to get 25 off site-wide
during their anniversary sale that's 25
off sitewide at cutsclothing.com one
division why wandovision i assume our we
just have a deal with this company and
that's just the one we used last time we
did a deal with them don't think about
it one division is ever present in our
lives and if you aren't re-watching it
every weekend like i am
you should seriously it's always topical
and we want to thank stamps.com for
sponsoring this episode if you're going
to go to the post office and paying full
price for postage stop it thanks to
stamps.com you don't have to do that
anymore mail and ship anytime anywhere
right from your computer send letters
ship packages and pay less a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups and
more stamps.com saves businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
every year whatever kind of shipping
you're doing stamps.com can handle it
with ease new rockstars has used in the
past to ship all kinds of stuff
including getting equipment to remote
employees like being mt right now it was
super easy and very helpful you could
use your computer to print official us
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off with stamps.com
you get discounts up to 40 off post
office rates and up to 66 off ups
shipping rates with promo code marvel
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in marvel that's
stamps.com promo code marvelstamps.com
never go to the post office again all
right empty back to the episode what if
the blip was an absolute point in the
mcu i want to talk more about absolute
points could the blip have been an
absolute point in that reality or in
some other reality what what are
absolute points and how important will
absolute points be to the future the way
marvel explains the multiverse and
things like time travel that's a really
good question eric because i feel like
it could actually be this absolute point
within the mcu because
he who remains didn't stop it from
happening i feel like that's a really
interesting point so and like absolute
points actually remind me of the term
fixed points from doctor who because i'm
a huge you know doctor who fanny which
is literally exactly what this is this
like you know you can't change this
moment because it's a pivotal moment in
like in all time um but yeah i think
that it's a really it's a
huge traumatic event that happens to
everybody in the universe so like it it
has to be like probably the most
absolute point of all absolute points
because it is so
universally effective but like what do
you think do you think yeah well i think
uh at least the avengers were confronted
with uh changing that as if that was an
absolute point because they didn't
necessarily stop the blip from happening
it still happened people still aged up
five years they just found some loophole
to kind of extract the stones from the
past and bring them to the present to
you know uh to bring everyone back but
they couldn't like prevent or stop
thanos's snap from happening but let's
be honest this episode completely
rewrites the rules of time travel
that we are presented in game and
presented
what
like even the way the time stone works
like you're supposed to rewind through
time like you rewind the apple being
eaten you rewind wanda blowing up the
mind stone and vision's forehead and
it's almost like tenant like you see
reverse time in almost real time maybe a
little bit slower maybe a little bit
faster but the freaking way dr strange
did it
and then
oh sorry
you can't do that you can't rewind i
can't do that thank you thank you i
appreciate that agreed you can't do that
and he just like teleported right back
to that moment which we hadn't seen the
time stone work like that before so you
could just argue look this is what if
these animators are doing all kinds of
weird [ __ ] with timelines with
characters mouths moving i'll be honest
that's so true
the ancient one
looks so weird uh but look they are
taking all kinds of liberties i think we
could say on what if that um maybe kevin
feige is just like oh it's animated
but
do think it is interesting how
many new points i think an absolute
point is something that is interesting
also that the time stone itself has a
different kind of magic it's on a
different scale than uh the technology
that seems to fuel the tva and what he
remains was doing i think we can agree
with that right oh yeah absolutely like
it's it's i feel like a time stone in
this reality like you were sort of
alluding to there it just seems very
like a lot different in terms of the way
it acts i i don't know this is it due to
impart to strange desperation in this
universe compared to you know of our
main universe whereas he didn't need the
time stone as much as he needed it now
so like maybe he's like reading through
these books is like all right now i have
a greater understanding of this time
stone so like i can do you know that
weird [ __ ] like i'm just gonna teleport
here immediately type of stuff so like
yeah yeah right now it seems like marvel
studios is trying to keep a division
between magic and science still even
though they are the same thing blah blah
insert the thor line we just don't
understand
um but specifically kang slashie who
remains was using technology the quantum
realm time travel that they did in any
game was technology they use terms like
epr paradox the deutsche proposition
whereas what dr strange does is magic uh
and i think at the end of the day it is
all magic but when the ancient one said
to bruce banner like
you're gonna create uh alternate
timelines by doing this that's kind of
what she told doctor strange in this
episode you're now on a dark path that i
think we sat nas i think we now saw that
uh alternate dark timeline that she
warned bruce banner about and we follow
it and we live on and eventually what we
learn is that those timelines kind of
prune themselves
and that's what we saw dr strange and at
the end is if you try to change an
absolute point
and
uh and if you're successful eventually
your universe is gonna self-prune
uh and then everyone you know is gonna
like melt into ink
and then rejoin the dark she kind of
talked about the dark dimension and you
talked about in recent videos this idea
of like
there's kind of this dark matter
that fills in the buffer points of the
void and that seems like what was
happening in that reality it just kind
of rejoins the void of the universe and
it uh it just melts in a weird way that
looks very cool looks super cool i love
that imagery um but yeah no i think that
that it's a really interesting point
there because like you know it's i feel
like it makes sense for the universe to
sort of self prune in the event that
like something goes wrong and it's like
you know what like this is it's sort of
like a i don't know i this is probably a
bad example but like a cancer cell
overgrowing it's just like oh no like
this is not natural and so like the i'm
going to die now because like this is
just not the way things are supposed to
go so yeah i think i think ultimately we
can conclude though that absolute points
are only absolute to their specific
universe because in the mcu we didn't
need christine palmer to die
you know she's still alive she's doing
fine so but i think what we're finding
is that every universe has at least one
absolute point it is not shared across
different universes different timelines
but uh i what i'm now asking is can
there be multiple absolute points just
these kind of load-bearing points in
history that can be unchanged um and
it's just interesting that this episode
makes it seem like uh you can't subvert
you've got to imagine the countless
times dr street just trying to save her
it wasn't just preventing the car
accident it was just like deciding to
let her drive deciding to go get pizza
decide to go dancing eventually she's
gonna die and i
made it seem like the blip was not that
to the mcu
if they could kind of subvert it in that
way
okay interesting i get that just
different rules
different rules i think we're more
willing to accept it and what if this
honestly seems like a hypothetical
cautionary tale a truly tragic event of
a character that goes too far
i feel like this this episode was was
made specifically i mean obviously like
it's an amazing episode but like i feel
like the main goal of this episode was
so that it demonstrates that the watcher
will not intervene no matter how bad the
situation is and the universe literally
ended he was like well that's what
happens you know see you later
great now uh next question we gotta talk
about fisto what if one of those mystic
entities was actually mephisto or
evidence of his existence how should we
interpret that empty
i think that you know there's obviously
a lot of demon imagery in this episode
and like it's impossible not to think
about mephisto honestly like it's
it's straight up like the imagery or the
illusions are sort of there um but i
think
that if it was one of those entities was
mephisto
um
maybe strange would be a little bit more
powerful i don't know i feel like
mephisto is this like super juiced up
entity but it's totally possible i like
that that being that uh strange turns
into at the very end i'm just like damn
that is
uh give me some like dem demon mephisto
vibes i mean obviously mephisto doesn't
look like that but like i don't know
maybe he swallowed a little bit of a
fisto maybe at his fingernail or
something
what do you think i mean i i honestly
think empty the fact that he was able to
see the watcher and he was as powerful
as he was makes it more likely that
there was some kind of at least a brush
an elbow bumping with mephisto in there
you know
he got a taste a taste of the fish
but i think ultimately we can say this
episode dispels those i always hated
this counter argument to mephisto saying
disney will never put demonic imagery on
their platform like
dumbass have you seen fantasia
have you seen hocus pocus
there's satan and all that stuff are you
crazy
disney has no problem with that and
clearly this episode proves it uh disney
plus is not afraid to show demonic
imagery so i think uh if disney's not
afraid to do that here and i i don't
think they have a problem with doing it
in any live action thing uh i just think
this episode was all about priming the
pump with audiences and getting us used
to this idea that doctor strange is a
guy connected to crazy cosmic horror and
scary [ __ ] and i think that's the
direction we're gonna go firmly in
multiverse of madness i think my most
anticipated event honestly mt is not
spiderman no way home it is the trailer
for doctor strange in the multiplayer oh
yes i cannot wait to see the visual
language and i believe they're using the
same production designer as spider-man
no way home so okay okay good we got
that's got the synergy there that's
that's good yeah um but yeah no that
trailer's gonna be nuts like it's gonna
be like the end of that trailer like the
thing that like hooks you in at the end
it's gonna be like oh my god like it's
a true multiverse of madness i think
what it's gonna look at like the very
first time i saw the doctor strange
trailer and i believe that was summer
2016 i remember feeling like what am i
looking at this does not look like any
marvel film i've seen before so i'm just
excited to have that feeling again of
like oh yeah magic uh translated in a
new way hell yeah man hell yeah
um now the last question i want to ask
him t is uh what if mordo was missing
for a reason he was the one major
character from the first doctor strange
film not here so what was it do you
think they just couldn't get chihuatel
and they didn't want to recast him with
a sound alike actor or
is there something in the works for him
for multiverse of madness that they
didn't want to
complicate
well i think it's a a matter of uh they
couldn't get chio until egypt four and
she would tell egf5 was unavailable
no
no i think that um
so ridiculous oh no i think that mordo
was definitely missing for a reason here
because uh i because he's a ve like the
fact that he wasn't in commerce at all
and like the fact that mordo was this
jiminy cricket type figure for dr
strange in doctor strange one the fact
that he didn't have that and he goes on
this super dark path i think that sort
of ties into what you were saying before
about like those secret like side
what-if scenarios and i think that you
know what if mordo wasn't around to you
know sort of give doctor strange some
[ __ ] is a big factor to why all of this
happens because you're just like all
right i'm just gonna do what i want
because i know wong said you know don't
do it i'm gonna make some tea and the
ancient one definitely said you know
don't do it by her all of her actions
but i definitely think that mordo not
being there was a big factor to why this
whole episode went to [ __ ] because
yeah mourinho he's not wrong bordeaux's
not wrong so and like honestly after all
this maybe mordo is right there are too
many sorcerers there are like this is
just it's not good it's it's having
sorcerers being able to swallow up
interdimensional creatures uh not great
doesn't seem like it's a good idea
yeah this uh i think not having mordo in
there made this kind of story a bit like
more straightforward um because you know
i you know with all these uh what-if
episodes they really streamline the
stories they fly through it and i think
specifically they needed the ancient one
to be dead and then wong to be kind of
the the character he is like wong is
almost like a watcher that he doesn't
intervene in spider-man no way home the
guy packed up suitcases says don't you
do that spell
and leaves so i i think they just needed
strange to be a bit unsupervised to be
able to tell this story and had mordo uh
been in the room he would have been like
ah give me that
put it on a real high shelf
he just rolls up a newspaper just pops
up on the head he's like no you can't do
that
um but i am very excited to see what
comes next from chippewa tele84 i think
he's an amazing actor and i and i loved
his take on mordo he's just the guy's
costly freaking out i knew i should have
stayed home today
we can't do this turn down the music do
we have neighbors we share walls
um so he's just great i think the
universe needs more mordos i identify
more with a mordo than a strange my idea
of a good time is sitting at home by
myself playing wingspan
if we want to say yes to this episode i
want to segue right into a wig space but
i don't want to explore the multiverse i
want to stay at home and
with my lovely girlfriend fiance
and soon to be wife and my dog that's
all i ever want to do multi wingspan of
madness that's all about it
well that's it for this episode of
inside marvel mt and i will be back next
wednesday with our what if episode 5
reaction now my breakdown i know you're
used to my breakdowns coming out the
same day we didn't get early advanced
screening to this episode we i just
watched it minutes ago it's gonna take
me a time this is a complex thick
episode there's a lot in it magical
episode i wanna do it right so it's
going to come out tomorrow be patient if
people yell at me on twitter you yell
back at them be my defenders don't make
me get all rattled because twitter eric
is not having fun with it
twitter eric isn't good at interacting
with others
it's twitter.com the answer is to just
get off twitter but i can't i can't i
haven't
uh
but anyway don't forget to check out our
many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com including this
lovely shirt you too can have your crazy
theory or question answered read aloud
featured on screen
by just getting this now you can follow
me at ea boss follow mt mastertainment
follow new rockstar subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
and thank you for watching we'll close
with our favorite moment of the episode
this way sorcerer armani no it's it's
strange not any stranger than any other
name in this world
[Music]
foreign